[Music]
how you doing
can you see me I'm at my in it yeah okay
how you doing
can I get can I get a triple your
husband is your husband okay can I get
him a chair please sit down here yeah
what's your name
Andrea how you do it yeah that's good my
name is Ali and when I want to do
something surprising today okay and what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to shake your
hand and I'm gonna tell you why I'm
doing that and hopefully the context
wouldn't make you feel a bit
uncomfortable so first I want to shake
your hand now the reason why I'm shaking
your hand is Islamically as Muslims we
are not allowed to shake shake opposite
genders handle yeah your name is sorry
and Andrea Andrea my name is Eric so now
that depends because on in its now we
believe in prevention is better than
cure
now this does not mean that when I shake
a young lady's hand I'm gonna be getting
all kind of ideas in my head yeah now we
believe in God Almighty and god almighty
tells us that he knows us best how he
created men how he created woman the
weaknesses of men and the weakness is a
woman so we are also told that if for
example somebody is at a certain age
that it is okay for us to shake their
hand so for example like you say that
for example you look you look young but
the thing is I there's people that you
deem for example that are a bit like you
say bit older than yourself yeah in that
context it's not that's why I shake your
hand and a lot people gonna be like the
hell's going on
now the reason behind that is because if
you have you heard of them there was a
whole scandal about me to hash tag here
so there was these rapes candles and
stuff that was happening oh so sorry
sorry sorry sorry sir yes I'll Road out
over here so there was a whole scandal
going in here
that would arise from things that would
happen in the workplace people that a
woman that were being sexually abused in
schools great so different people who
different from shaking hands oh of
course of course now what happened was
there was certain regulations that are
now putting place in workplaces yeah so
friends are from what I've heard that
they say when a man and a woman is in a
you this is something the door should be
open right sure regulations now in New
York I can't remember where I think it
was specific building where they you
know they do not you know trading even
there they said for to touch a woman as
you're talking to an S suppose we're
examined touching her knee so these
things were seen as some people were
coming out and saying I was
uncomfortable with that I don't I don't
I do not like you to touch me so there
was a host can do like about couple of
months ago where they were discussing
this you know what is appropriate for
example touching their me because as I
was growing or no before year but we
were meant for each other
the things of like touching the remember
at school he think I handed him an
eraser a rubber he might all my hand
longer than he should have do that in
our society that says always interested
it's not the case for me to have been
violated this seems there's no cutoff
point and the needs to be 100 percent I
think like Muslims not shaking a woman's
hand because it might be interpreted I
think that's too far it's okay I respect
where you're gonna shake my hand I'm
really surprised because I've watched
yeah yes so now the reason being is
because you see we believe in prevention
rather than cure now the reason why
Islam legislates that and this is this
course we offer excuses one if there was
a Jewish man here you asking to shake
your head yeah he may not do that
and if he's a offer of Christian
person as well now we believe prevention
is better than cure so be alcohol be it
drugs
be it intimacy before marriage we
believe these things lead to things that
internally affect us so that's the
reason why it stances look how cool god
almighty told us in the Quran there is
some good in it but the harm our ways
the good and it's the root of all evil
so I was speaking to a young lady that
she knew somebody who died in a car
accident because of a drunk driver and
her face was burnt yeah now what we say
is that we believe this Stan believes
that the whole community should be
preserved and be protected so if an
individual comes and says I want to
drink alcohol or I want to have intimacy
before marriage or I want to do drugs we
say okay you may want to do that but why
impact is that gonna have on society if
the society Azhar who's gonna be
affected you can't do that but coming to
the shaking hand bit you see aging a
person who's an alcoholic
they never the somebody says arm just a
casually I have one glass a week but it
all starts with one class a week so it
comes back to the the example that I'm
given of shaking hand now that doesn't
mean if I shake a woman's hand
automatically I'm gonna be back oh there
we go let me go in to have a one-night
stand with her or dude no but what it is
is to protect myself that even something
that some I knew that we could say you
know what come on for God's sake what on
earth is wrong we shake in a woman's
hand or hey and by the way it's vice
versa a Muslim woman can't shake and not
a man's hand is well so it works both
ways it's not just me and it's got
nothing to do if it was a Muslim woman
standing in front of me with a veil and
she said can I shake her now say no so
it's not about being a Muslim or
non-muslim it's going to do just to the
female is done both ways so we say it's
better for us to abstain from that
because one thing can lead to another
now shaking hands might not happen at
that but for example if you're in a
workplace and there's a you have a
secretary who were people the time to
shake hands it all starts with something
and that's why Islam eclis if I'm
interested in a man well you said for
example if you will give a ruler you'll
hold on to your hand more than you
should
yeah so so him holding on to your hand
would give you the impression he likes
me yes that is not a bad thing that's
good luck if you like someone that's
normal human beings you might like
somebody Islam also tells us how to go
about Nike and someone so it doesn't
tell us not to love not to have emotions
and feelings how to regulate that so if
I like somebody I have to go and speak
to their father
wide wide boundaries why do we have
boundaries I have to go to speak to the
father why because the father is the
Guardian and if I am serious about her I
would have no problem speaking to the
father in religion I mean like with my
marriage you know the first time we've
just been in we've sat and had a drink
there's something to me and there was a
couple of Muslim girls full gown on and
everything and on the next table there's
two girls with miniskirts on yeah and I
we were talking about it and I said it's
like you could bring your own wife up so
you can't look at her yeah but yes
you're looking at will the girls
and I and as a person as a woman I
wouldn't like that it's like making new
the girls stand out more
yes is it because okay no I would say
that to say Muslim men do have I would
say in general a man's weakness is a
woman hands down no man can deny that
okay I would say that we be over
generalization because I would say for
example that certain men from all
backgrounds should control this so it
shouldn't be specific to anyone but if
that man has his wife covered up now his
wife is covering up not for him
Muslim woman do not cover up for their
husbands they cover and the reason they
cover up is for good for example did you
know as a Muslim man I have to cover
myself for my Mayville to my knee I have
to Islamic Lee when I go swimming I
cannot show below my like my tummy area
you know here yeah okay
I don't have a six-pack but I I'm not
allowed to show it and that's that's my
hijab my modesty so I have to grow the
beard I have to go to this the believing
men and the believing woman lower your
gazes so what he said to me about this
man whose wife was there he was looking
at girl with miniskirt he's violating
this actual pin where God says you
should lower your case why are you even
looking at another woman so regardless
how your wife is dressed if she's
dressed up in a miniskirt I bet you
because it's an internal matter even if
he's wives dressed up in miniskirt he's
talking on a card only because the
matter is internal the problem is not
what the woman is the problem is with
the man because he can't control his
eyes so that's why it's important for us
that's room for him to do that in any
other man cuz I don't know of men
catcalling yeah that for example you see
that unlocked you see a lot of young
woman who are suffering in rape
yeah being sexually you know violated in
different ways and being treated like
they're I'm thinking to myself why you
whistle in the sheets some kind of you
it's your dog that oh hey there gorgeous
hey miss we say we honor woman she's
somebody else's mother
somebody else's brought up somebody
else's sister okay it is a compliment
but that should come from your husband
so what we see is why should he
imagine if he went and whistled to
another woman you wouldn't like that he
has been trying to get me to go out with
him for 40 years
well my own I think the way you could
have maybe glad somebody could go about
it is wait if the marriage doesn't work
out and approaches say you know what
actually we last you for a long time and
I'm sure he could have that could have
worked as well okay and all right so
that that would have that would have
worked as well but the thing is it's
there for us to be like honorable
because we want to treat each other in
an honorable way so that's the reason
why when I like somebody I have to go to
the Father why because I'm seeing I'm
serious about you I want to marry you I
want to spend the rest of my life with
you
I have no problem speaking to you attack
however if I have the wrong intentions
and I warn you for the wrong reasons I
don't want to speak to you that I don't
want to speak to nobody think this is
why there's something a lot of the gang
rapes I can rather among that because
Muslims look at white girls only think
reason very good point
why would say is this these men who are
committing these viral arts number one
for us to save their Muslims we can say
okay we are Muslims but to bring their
religion into it is contradictory
why because are they actual definition
their religion says you are know enough
to rape a woman you are not allowed to
touch her
I promise oh sorry I promise you I
promise you
nowhere in the Quran it says that we
should kill you it's a Christian or a
Jewish person or it just say I know
which verse is it's talking about
surah sort of my device I'll open it for
you what it says is the following
I'm just gonna find it for here and in
the meantime where I'm finding it for
you sorry there you go surah surah my
verse 32 if I'm not mistaken yet this is
what it says for this reason we decreed
for the children of Israel that whoever
kills a person not in retaliation for a
person killed nor as the punishment for
spreading disorder on the earth as if he
has been it's as if he has killed the
whole of humankind and whoever saves the
life of a person is as if he saved the
life of the whole humankind certainly
our messengers have come to them with
clear signs and in the next verse those
who fight against Allah and His
Messenger and run about trying to spread
disorder on the earth their punishment
is no other than that they should be
killed or they should be crucified or
their hands and legs be called from
different sites ok ok ok let me put it
like this Andrea would it be barbaric
because this is talking about specific
context that is not even talking about
the Christians of the Jews this is
talking about Muslim highway robbers
there was a group of you and this how
the story goes because this is the
backstory of why it was revealed imagine
you and your husband are walking about
your business in Hyde Park a group of
gangs come up to you
yeah they kill him they take your money
and they run off this verse is talking
about those who are spreading corruption
on earth because you was walking
peacefully minding your own business why
did you have to come and take innocent
man's life why did you have to put
horror in society why did you have to
steal the belongings of a woman so this
is what God Almighty says and this is
the ruling the shadow ruling goes if
they come and stop you guys
yeah and steal your stuff and they don't
kill you their hands will be cut off
if they stop you and steal your stuff
kill somebody innocent they will be cut
their hands weak on each side crucified
and then they will be killed
why now you might say barbaric but it's
Nam what does it come to again
prevention is better than cure
because if Islam has legislated everyone
to live in peace why are you going and
stopping an innocent couple walking down
the road causing this disaster killing a
lot
you